they constantly tell us that everyone
should come to america and we should
give them a lot of stuff and we should
have open borders and everyone should
share and apparently the horror of our
race is patriarchy but they still want
to come it's all very bizarre but then
reality hits them and next thing you
know in places like new york city
they're being overrun with people that
they cannot support here is new york
city mayor eric adams who i have no
doubt will soon be called a racist by
his leftist cohorts this is a real
burden on new yorkers as we're trying to
do the right thing
uh
we already as i stated we already have
an overburdened shelter system so now
we're talking about as you stated food
clothing school
this is going to impact our of our
schools because we do not turn away
individuals because they're undocumented
translation services there's just a
whole host of things that this is going
to produce and that's why we need we
need help and getting this done and we
need the right coordination to make it
happen
it's it's hilarious it's actually
hilarious that these people think if you
just let a gajillion people in you don't
check anything you give them services
that eventually it's not going to
collapse the system it's happening
everywhere also the dc mayor we covered
it earlier in the week is dealing with
the same thing her homeless shelters are
being overrun by illegals uh alicia you
live in l.a um how many homeless people
are you how many homeless people are you
sheltering right now because that's why
i left
um
not uh sheltering any of them we've got
a lot of gates and a moat and a few guns
and stuff like although i shouldn't be
saying that on air because the atf might
come knocking on my door but they'd have
to come through the two fences first
there you go but uh it is actually
heartbreaking that i i say this all the
time downtown la i think has so much
potential uh uh just a week before that
poor olympian was clocked and almost
lost sight we'll get to
yeah a friend of mine was bitten on the
back of a head by a homeless person this
goes back to leftist policies like in
general though since before you and i
were born it's the not in my backyard
they will say that they want these
things to happen until they actually
start to happen and then they realize oh
wow government is not the end all be all
and we don't have the resources to take
care of these people because guess what
turns out the government really sucks at
taking care of people they shouldn't be
doing it they should be minimizing their
involvement and letting the free market
speak for itself and we should be
protecting our borders because when we
protect our borders and we have an
immigration process that is legal and
that works it's beneficial not just to
current american citizens but the ones
that want to come here and when my buddy
ben shapiro and i used to do a morning
show we would say all the time we'd
actually rather trade uh probably a
couple million fellow millennials for
these immigrants that want to come here
because their ideology aligns more with
the values of our judeo-christian nation
than kids that were born in this country
so i'm not anti-immigration i want
people to come here but it is not
beneficial to them or to us and it's
definitely not sustainable if we just
like do what la and dc new york do and
say well come on in
and by the way i live in miami right now
which is a hugely immigrant often first
or second generation immigrant city
filled with cubans and venezuelans these
are people who know what their parents
or they fled so they're the most
pro-american people you can possibly
find uh james does this eric adams
situation sort of go to something that
you and i have discussed publicly and
privately for years i've taken the
position for a long time that the good
liberals cannot do anything in the face
of this thing it simply does not work
they try to be nice but they just end up
adding fuel to the fire so in this case
eric adams who is a democrat but they
thought okay he's not a completely
insane democrat he's not the socialist
lunatic bill de blasio he'll do a little
bit better except here we are and it's
obvious that here we are and he doesn't
know how to deal with it and he also
said in there he's not going to stop
them from coming he's just going to ask
for help i don't know who he's asking
but that the good libs they simply
actually at this point are causing the
problem while they're pretending that
they're doing something about it
and i completely agree they have
absolutely no tools whatsoever at their
disposal to try to stop any of this we
could also turn and look at how the
trans lobby is just absolutely
overriding all of feminism like feminism
doesn't exist anymore the the the truth
is that the machine always moves left
the dialectical machine is what it's
called it always moves left and they
don't have any tools to stop it um we do
have to add a little piece of context
that i don't know for sure that it's
relevant but when we look at eric adams
when we look at what you just said with
the immigrants coming in we'll also
remember that the courts just decided
that immigrants can't vote in
new york and so all of a sudden they're
a problem
so what you see is this kind of like
pie in the sky vision for how they can
transform reality to this kind of utopia
that doesn't work in reality that they
can't manage and the good leftists or
good lefties or whatever we want to call
them very smart people they're idiots
they
literally have no tools to deal with it
they can't do anything to stop it and
frankly it's largely because they don't
they just frankly don't understand
what's happening in the world around
them they have if you know i tell people
a lot of times you know if there's a
scale of one to ten of how well people
understand the political world around
them my typical smart college educated
masters degree left wing friend is about
a three
on a good day they just don't know
what's happening in the world around
them so they're useless at best and
causing the problem at worst
they have phds and yet they never
learned you wouldn't want to say heroin
addict taking a dump in a park next to a
lady with a stroller
i don't know they just don't teach that
at yale i thought they did libby what
should people who live insane states
insane cities and i apologize alicia i
know and you're always welcome here uh
what should we be should we waste our
time talking about this nonsense anymore
or should we just let new york city go
let seattle go like stop talking about
it stop thinking about it you guys want
this congratulations we're just washing
our hands on it we don't do the country
or the world any favors by destroying
our cities
and i i think that that would be really
a shame to just say we're going to let
new york city go with all of its great
cultural contributions that it's done
over the years i think there's a chance
for new york city i think
the city operates best when it's under
republican leadership even as the state
typically has
democratic leadership um and i think
that new yorkers should be voting
conservative i think that they should be
voting for you know
people who are interested in maintaining
new york city instead of watching it run
to ruin kamala harris had been tasked
with dealing with the root causes of
immigration she has done nothing perhaps
eric adams should take his plea to save
new york to her but certainly mayors
across the country should not be held
responsible for the biden
administration's total failure to secure
the border and to make sure that the
people who are being led into this
country are not criminals who are here
to destroy our country instead of be
you know functioning members of society
and it's really a shame too for the
hispanic community which has done so
much for this country and contributed so
much to have people just running across
the border
completely unchecked when you have so
many people who came here legally or who
earned citizenship
through legal channels so i think adams
should be perhaps more outspoken than
this he should take his fight directly
to the white house he should tell them
to stop destroying new york city and
miami and all of these other great
places that so many americans call home
right the problem is the problem is we
know we know he's not going to do that
and by the way you know where this all
ends i mean right now we've got florida
and texas busing i want to i want to
tell adams to do it
oh yeah yeah we could we could keep
telling him to do it i don't think he's
going to do it but you know this all
ends this all ends obviously with
florida and texas bussing these illegals
that the biden administration allows in
they're going to keep bussing them to
new york new york is eventually going to
start busting them out and then we end
up in basically mad max
fury road where it's just going to be
competing buses going in different
directions all trying to take each other
out